the black sea port city of odessa is
preparing for an offensive by russian
troops odessa's mayor says the russian
military could soon surround the city on
three sides effectively cutting it off
from the rest of the country locals are
volunteering to defend their hometown
and say they're ready to put up a fight
as dw's alexander fonnaman reports
we are in the center of odessa and you
can see that the port city has been
turned into a fortress checkpoints and
barricades built of sandbags have been
erected throughout the city
we are ready every day we go to sleep
fully dressed to be ready to seek
shelter in anticipation of a missile
strike most
shoveling sand into sandbags on odessa's
beach to strengthen the city's defenses
volunteers such as alexander an engineer
say they want to make themselves useful
but we are trying to
support each other we are trying to
[Music]
organize ourselves and you know
so many people here i never know before
but now we are work as a team and this
is the perfect example and this is what
we should do
odessa is of tremendous strategic
importance for the ukrainians and that
makes the city a likely russian target
in capturing odessa's ports russia would
be able to cut off ukraine from the
black sea and from all supplies coming
in by ship
time and again air raid sirens go off
and residents have to seek shelter
it's almost too much to bear alexandra
tells me her family has lived in odessa
for four generations but now alexandra
says it's time for her and her daughter
to flee
i've been thinking a lot should i leave
my home my family my husband
you spend your money enough it's so hard
you take only the necessities and go but
everything is necessary
i wake up and my mom says we need to
take cover we take the cat the phone and
hide in the hole we sit there until the
alarm is over
[Music]
many people have already left believing
that it's just a question of time before
moscow tries to capture odessa
odessa's ties with russia stretch back
many centuries the city founded by
russian empress catherine the great is
still largely russian speaking but
despite the deep seated connections that
people of odessa are prepared to meet
putin soldiers with fierce resistance
we visited a school that's now a
volunteer center natalia is in charge
here her message to the russian troops
is simple
we don't want to be liberated we are
living wonderfully we don't need to be
liberated they should not make up any
myths about that or believe them and use
them as a pretext to violate our
peaceful life
natalia says odessans wants to keep
their city and they are ready to fight
for it
you